i'm jessie waters along with judge
jeanine pierrot harold ford jr kaylee
mcinenny and greg gutfeld it's five
o'clock in new york city and this is the
five
[Music]
[Applause]
police revealing brand new details
surrounding a horrific mass shooting in
highland park illinois during a fourth
of july parade the act of pure evil
leaving seven people dead and injuring
30 more authorities say just minutes ago
the suspect had two prior run-ins with
law enforcement
in april of 2019 an individual contacted
highland park police department
a week after learning of
mr primo attempting suicide the matter
was being handled by
mental health professionals at that time
the second occurred in september of 2019
a family member reported that cremo said
he was going to kill everyone and primo
had a collection of knives
the police responded to his residence
the police removed 16 knives a dagger
and a sword from primo's home
there were a combination of which i
don't have the exact count at least two
rifles uh
some
pistols and possibly a shotgun those
were seized at his father's home
pursuant to a search warrant yesterday
authorities also saying 21-year-old
robert cremo was disguised as a woman to
escape the scene and had planned the
attack for weeks in advance
we're learning he left warning signs
online that nobody caught including
posting very disturbing images and
videos unfortunately the carnage in
america over the weekend doesn't end
there 30 minutes south of the highland
park attack
68 people were shot in chicago and two
police officers were shot during a
philadelphia fourth of july fireworks
show thankfully they're going to be okay
democratic politicians wasting no time
to go directly after guns
each day we're reminded there's nothing
guaranteed about our democracy
nothing guaranteed about our way of life
we have to fight for it
defend it
and earn it by voting our founders
carried muskets not assault weapons
and i don't think a single one of them
would have said that you have a
constitutional right to an assault
weapon with a high capacity magazine
let's ask the question of
why enraged people in other civilized
nations in our world aren't committing
these crimes we know that this is a
unique american issue
and that's why we need to take necessary
steps we need to have a much stronger
conversation about why these weapons of
war are still permitted in our society
so judge what happened with this freak
cremo they seized his weapons yet he
still
unleashes hell on this parade
you know in the beginning and i have my
notes
he was not known to the police that's
what they told us but we know that there
generally is some crime something that
indicates there's a problem now we just
find out there were 17 knives that the
police seized from his home after he
threatened to kill everybody there were
apparently domestic violence calls to
his homes quote the police were there
all the time there were always police
cars at the house parents are arguing
and fighting all the time now is that
enough no but if you threaten to kill
someone and you're a loner and you've
got 19 knives or 17 and the police come
and say there's no grounds to arrest you
well i would take that cop on any day of
the week to me that is enough to make an
arrest and what we also know is he
attempted suicide he's got mental health
issues and and i haven't even touched
the social media yet now if this is a
small town is this a small town okay the
local cops
it's a suburb so the local cops should
know what's going on apparently the
mayor said something like
maybe it wasn't the mayor but they had
to call the parents to pick this kid up
from school it's like he didn't have any
family around him this kid once you
isolate everything around him you're you
have to know that this kid is going to
do something wrong whether or not you
would know he was going to take down you
know people at a parade it's disgusting
it's sad i don't even want to want to go
on talking about
recognizing the the horrible pain that
this town is in and the post-traumatic
stress syndrome that these people will
have as a result of this but
let's be clear about one thing when we
find people with knives and guns we
arrest them we keep them in jail we
prosecute them and we convict them when
we start recognizing that there's
consequences that have to be imposed
before you start going after the second
amendment maybe then we can have a
legitimate conversation yeah so if this
guy's homicidal suicidal he's armed to
the teeth he's got disturbing social
media footprints and he has facial
tattoos
why can't you throw this kid in a
straitjacket
you have a first of all belated happy
fourth everybody i love you too you are
um
you have a big problem with facial
tattoos i do that should maybe be
someone we arrest or people we arrest
everywhere
a couple things one um
i think at some point
we everyone around this table and around
the country has to
sort of wrestle with
how do we want to recalibrate the way we
think about police fighting
law enforcement
our laws on the books be it the
shootings in chicago or the shooting in
highland park at some level we have to
sit back understand that you can't go to
a concert or a parade or a church or to
school or stand out on your corner or
for that matter uh can you imagine what
we're going to do here in new york i was
rotting in and we might the driver bless
his heart he cut off a guy i don't think
he realized he cut the goblin the guy
was honking his horn all i could think
was if this guy had a gun
he might fire at us of fire in the car
so we've got to think long and hard
about all of this i you know i i try to
tell my party on energy that we should
be different we've got to we got to
rescind our position on the keystone
pipeline and reverse it we've got to
drill more why why do i say this not
because i don't want to have a green
energy platform in the country but
because
we are at war in ukraine and the
russians have an upper hand the same way
europe depends so heavily on oil and
energy products from russia we in
america depend on semiconductor chips
and other technology from asia one of
the reasons i say we have to invest in
congress please pass the chips act
democrats and republicans alike look
back at guns and where we are we have a
public safety challenge
now i'm not saying guns is the total
answer but one of the jobs principal
roles of the legislature anywhere in the
country and for that amount of the
federal legislature is when a problem
presents itself everyone's got to not
retreat to their little sit corners and
hold their little sacred positions on
things that frankly sound good on a
piece of paper sound good and a sound
bite but we have a problem now i'm not
saying removing guns is all of the
answer but something the tattooed guy
the tattoo face guys these kids these
guys are 21 and younger most of them are
kids who come from some some households
that may not everything may not be in
place and here's what we should do also
if we're going to arrest the tattoo guy
we shouldn't let him buy a gun
because they've proven not to be
responsible with guns and this is not an
attack on the second amendment this is
an attack on people trying to kill
people how do we identify that person
that's where we ought to spend our money
and our time and just just just but
loosely talking about mental health is
not the issue here we know who the the
profile of these kinds of kids and we
ought to we ought to spend a lot of time
and effort and money to ensure that they
don't get guns yeah but it looks like
the officials in illinois blew it didn't
they they did um you know i agree with
harold in part i agree about the
importance of dialogue and not talking
points you look at france which has very
onerous laws when it comes to guns
charlie hebdo shooting a legal weapon
paris attack which killed 129 a legal
weapon to laos shooting which almost
happened on a train which was thwarted a
legal weapon if you're sensing a trend
you should also very rare we have
reporters asking the right questions
that was an example of reporters asking
the right questions how many times did
they ask why didn't you involuntarily
confine this guy we heard it while it's
situational that's not enough if i'm the
legislature right now in the state of
illinois i'm looking at the laws for
involuntary confinement when you have
someone who articulates their plan
specifically in advance we saw this in
michigan with the school shooting where
the kid literally drew on a piece of
paper what he was about to do that
morning
we saw it in uvalde where the individual
texted someone and said i want to shoot
up in elementary school they always
articulate their threat 60 of the time
as i never cite the new york times but i
will in this case 60 percent of the time
so we need to figure out what we do when
someone articulates a threat because
letting them just have free reign is
simply not the answer greg gutfeld
yeah um
i think that when
every one of these cases these fiends
fit a type they're these very white
unstable
disturbing looking people and i really
do feel that you know you can judge a
book by its cover in some cases you can
i think there's a correlation between
uh disturbing unstable behavior and
people who deliberately try to make
themselves look unappealing unappealing
and unapproachable that could be their
cry for help i mean if you look at
antifa
i mean
that's how they look so i think that
like there is a red flag there that a
lot of people in the name of what will
not
point out and go when somebody is
deliberately trying to deface themselves
permanently or look in a way that makes
them unapproachable what are they trying
to tell you if beauty is a guide of
what's possible then what is deliberate
ugliness like why does somebody do that
we don't ask that anymore as people
continue to deface themselves and in in
in so many different ways again i will
i'm going to be an old uh what do you
call it an old saw on this uh it wasn't
suicide it was suicide plus the only
reason why you do that is to create a
spectacle for attention so i think this
one is a pretty pretty square case of a
copycat because it happened on the heels
of these other ones so what's the point
there if there are enough mass shootings
to see these trends uh to see that
they're mostly young white males not all
of them but they're rare enough that you
can look at each one of them so if you
take them away from gang shootings from
domestics or any kind of gun use in the
purpose of a crime just look at people
shooting for the sake of shooting it's
always influenced by the previous attack
so if you thought that you could if you
thought that you could decrease these
attacks by 30 40 50
why wouldn't you do it why wouldn't you
do it the media could do that we could
just report the facts be one and done
and leave instead of giving just
non-stop coverage the meeting the media
remember they could decide not to not to
cover something
hunter's laptop they were easy with that
border chaos they don't cover that the
riots after george floyd's mostly
peaceful he didn't cover that look at
the akron shooting right they said that
they said they covered the 60 shots from
the police but not the fact that the guy
shot first so they know how to not cover
things so i think it's time that we look
at this stuff and decide enough's enough
if we the press can decrease these
shootings by 30
why the hell don't we
you're right and i think we all need to
be better at criminally profiling people
i'm criminally profiling you you should
right you should because i stole your
lunch that's right i went on brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now